all right evil friends it's 2021 what
evil thing should we do today we could
use a network of hackers to steal the
identity of thousands
we could use an army of bots to spread
our propaganda on twitter
we could steal billions for ourselves
via combination of underpaying workers
insider trading and tax evasion
we could develop a monopoly over
everyone's childhood and control all of
entertainment
man being evil in 2021 sucks
hello internet welcome to film theory a
show that cares about the really
important issues preparing humanity for
the minion apocalypse right about now
you're probably wondering why i would
want to kill the minions on the surface
these adorable little henchmen who made
their first appearance in the 2010 film
despicable me have taken the world by
storm with their cuteness
unique language and obsession with
overalls seems like the worst they could
do is just annoy parents forced by their
kids to watch the antics of these little
yellow silos on repeat
over and over and over
and over again but today's episode isn't
just about preserving the sanity of
every parent out there watching though
you are welcome for that no it's about
preventing an
extinction level event think mad max
fury road but instead of riding flaming
cars you got a bunch of little yellow
tic tacs riding around monster banana
trucks for those of you who are light on
the lore the stated purpose of a minion
is to help in the creation of evil
they're all different but they all share
the same goal
to serve the most despicable master they
could find that's it that is their
driving cause in life the top of their
maslow hierarchy oh sure for the
majority of their existence they've been
mostly harmless serving dinosaurs
vampires the french but when things go
right for him
they quickly become really dangerous
when bob the minion becomes the king of
england he changes the country's laws to
give the crown to scarlet overkill a
woman who wants to rule via a strict
dictatorship to top it all off in
despicable me 3 they leave gru because
he's become less despicable and they
head out in search of a more evil
employer and you see this matters
because their numbers are rapidly
growing in a prior film theory episode
we learned via an official facebook post
that since teaming up with gru in 1968
their numbers have expanded from around
230 and minions to
10 400 by the time despicable me 3 rolls
around and sure
all this might not seem like a big deal
now that they're working for a guy whose
definition of evil is stealing trinkets
from the las vegas strip once grew and
his family aren't in the picture anymore
these henchmen will be looking for
another despicable boss and it could
mean
chaos death and destruction or they'll
just end up working for jeff bezos in
short these things are ticking time
bombs that are essentially immortal
indestructible and crave evil which is
why the world needs a plan
on how to stop them before they
potentially kill billions
so today as we prep for the eventual
name dare i say the inevitable minion
wars i'm gonna investigate these
creatures to find their weaknesses
so we can exploit them now this at first
might seem like it's an easy task
right like how tough could a little
yellow tic tac be but when you look
across all their movies and all their
related media the answer
is that they're practically
indestructible cold temperatures for
instance do not affect them
in the first despicable me a minion
floats off into space and doesn't freeze
to death in a place where temperatures
can reach minus 455 degrees fahrenheit
as minus 270 celsius that scene also
shows us that they don't need oxygen
since there's no air in space
humans meanwhile would be dead in about
a minute in space so the fact that it's
kicking around there for the better part
of a week
is mind-boggling speaking of biological
needs they don't appear to require
all that much food yeah they'll crush
bananas and ice cream into their faces
occasionally and very rarely do they
show signs of hunger but
judging from the fact that in the movie
minions we see them survive in an ice
cave from the time of the french
revolution in 1789
all the way until the year they meet
grew in 1968 that is 179
years without food starving them to
death isn't going to be a viable option
it's entirely possible that like other
long-living creatures such as tortoises
they can slow down their metabolism to
keep themselves alive in adverse
conditions or during hibernation so if
metabolic processes don't really offer
us a viable solution what about the good
old-fashioned ultraviolence
nope these things are impossibly durable
in the competition short on the minions
blu
ray two minions survive a 25 second fall
that's followed by two large missiles
exploding after checking out a free-fall
calculator for a loose calculation
that's about a 1.9 mile fall or three
kilometers followed by them being in
point-blank range of a missile explosion
and this isn't an isolated incident
either in despicable me we see an errant
rocket being
shot into a crowd of minions instead of
seeing limbs we see the minions looking
slightly scuffed and annoyed
this means the shrapnel that explodes
from the rocket doesn't penetrate the
minions skin
all this also tells us is that they're
resistant to heat temperatures of a
nuclear explosion get surprisingly hot
able to reach as high as the interior of
the sun about
100 million degrees celsius or 180
million degrees fahrenheit in minions we
see them afraid of a pool of lava which
would
at most be like 1250 celsius 2
282 fahrenheit but the fact that they
can ingest anything close to an atomic
warhead means that in reality they would
have nothing to be scared of
probably just fear the unknown right
like you could be resistant to lava too
but i don't encourage you to test that
out anytime soon
our next guest uh gave us well actually
very little information besides the fact
that he is uh
impervious to acid oh yeah oh yeah oh
yeah
in the franchise they've been bonked
crushed smashed and mashed and they just
keep going and not just going
they enjoy it torture makes them laugh
wow
harder than i thought next machine
seriously in minions they're placed in
medieval torture devices and they treat
it like a playground their bodies are
stretched
nooses don't seem to work on them and
the guy that's doing the torture is
legitimately impressed by their
toughness
also mass quantities of radiation don't
seem to have long lasting effects on
them either kevin gets bombarded with
mass quantities and minions becomes a
giant swallows a large rocket explodes
and walks away totally fine
so we can't blow them up drown them send
them into space or wait for them to die
in true cartoon character fashion they
seem to be completely indestructible
so what do we do how does humanity fight
back against these adorable little
yellow marshmallows now this might sound
crazy but i think it all boils down
to lobster now follow me on this in
despicable me 2 the film's main
antagonist el macho manages to kidnap
thousands of minions and what's he do
with them he alters their dna with a
mutagen that turns them into ravaging
monsters
this implies that the minions have dna
that we can exploit
and that isn't our only evidence in the
orientation day short film we see that
the minion clones all come from a sample
of minion dna
dna is their weakness their one and only
weakness so if we attack the dna we
attack
the minion which then merits the
question how do we attack the dna
well any creature that has a chance of
surviving as much torture as the minions
do for as long
as they do must have good repair enzymes
to prevent their dna from degrading and
that is where the lobsters come in you
see lobsters
and minions actually have a surprising
amount in common just like a minion the
american lobster can live for over a
hundred years
lobsters have an incredible ability to
regenerate and are capable of even
regrowing claws they can survive outside
of the water for weeks and when put in
cold water lobsters slow their
metabolism so they don't have to eat for
months
both have evolved from the ocean they've
been around for millions of years man
maybe we should title this video
minions are lobsters you know what if
this video does end up being called
minions or lobsters you'll know that it
was because the word kill was flagged by
youtube
anyway one of the reasons various
species of lobster can live over a
hundred years has to do with a special
enzyme called telomerase an enzyme that
constantly fixes the bits of the
telomere that are lost with each new
cell division which then begs the
question of what's a telomere and why is
it important well a telomere is the
non-coding dna
at the end of a chromosome that protects
the important dna found in the middle
it's kind of like a
bumper or buffer for the dna a good
comparison to this is you know how
shoelaces have that little plastic tip
at the end to prevent the shoelace from
fraying well that is
basically the role of the telomere also
fun fact that tip of the shoelace is
called an aglet
drop that little bit of knowledge on
your friend next time you see him anyway
each time a cell divides the telomere
gets shorter and shorter until
eventually they become so short that the
cell can't divide anymore
so by inhibiting the telomerase in the
minion we'd be able to make sure that
their cells can age
and degrade thus making them older and
more susceptible to infections viruses
and bacteria in essence we would be able
to make them human
and thus kill them but how do you
inhibit telomerase well here's the big
twist friends it's a step in a part of
many cancer treatments
many cancer treatments try to shut down
telomerase because cancer cells contain
active telomerase this is what makes
cancer so dangerous the active
telomerase allows the cancer cells to
continue dividing
uncontrolled essentially making the
cancer immortal but just like we talked
about with the lobsters without
telomerase activity these cells become
inactive they stop dividing
and they eventually die now when it
comes to humans one of the biggest
issues with these sorts of cancer
treatments is the worry of side effects
on the body since we're actively trying
to bump off the minions
unhealthy side effects just make the job
easier we want to make the minions
weaker and disrupt their wound healing
and ability to fight infection so
killing off telomerase in the body is
exactly what we're looking for
more good news for us minion hunters is
that back in 2010 the harvard gazette
announced that quote they achieved the
milestone in aging science by
engineering mice with a controllable
telomerase gene
the researchers bred mice without
telomerases and this
led to premature aging they then
reactivated the telomerase and the work
showed a dramatic reversal of the many
aspects of aging
including reversal of brain disease and
infertility the fact that scientists are
out there engineering animals with
telomerase genes that you can flip
on and off like a light switch tells us
that inhibiting telomerase is
possible in fact according to science
daily scientists as recently as 2018
have made great strides on exactly this
discovering how to shut off telomerase
using other enzymes that it tends to
work with
this in turn opens up a new opportunity
to indirectly block telomerase all of
this research and more has resulted in
the human telomerase reverse
transcriptase-derived vaccine
a very long-winded way of saying we
shoot a needle intia and we start
shutting the telomerase down this
also would presumably work in the world
of despicable me if engineered mutagens
like el macho's px41 can alter the
genetics of any living creature then a
vaccine or injection can most certainly
inhibit the telomerase of our immortal
little minions speaking of vaccines it's
worth noting that whatever we created
would need to be
injected into the minion why well in
panic in the mail room a short film
about the minions who work in gru's mail
room a minion swallows some of the px41
and becomes a purple ravaging monster
however the rampage comes to a halt when
the minion spits out the px41 and goes
back to normal so it's gotta get into
their system and stay in there somehow
luckily we know thanks to the home
makeover short film that pins
can penetrate minion bodies so those
little yellow dudes better be on the
watch out for any stray needles headed
their way
so there you have it friends how to kill
off the unkillable yellow skinned
overall clad monster
it's not about subjecting them to
extreme hot or cold cutting them off
from error food or confronting them with
guns and bombs it's about
taking the fight to their very cells to
bring down their deadliest superpower of
all
regenerating dna which come to think of
it in an ironic twist the most
despicable thing that gru has ever done
is withhold their genetic secret from
the world scientists have been trying to
crack the answer to immortality and
telomerase for decades and apparently
it's been sitting in gru's underground
bunker for the better part of 60 years
and that
my friends is the definitive way to kill
a minion i suppose you could also go the
route of you know making sure that their
new movies flop
but considering that this is a franchise
where four films have grossed a little
over 3.7 billion dollars at the
worldwide box office pretty sure
illumination entertainment ain't gonna
be killing off the franchise anytime
soon
but hey that's just a theory a film
theory and cut
[Music]
you